well Christmas is a time for a merry
mint and sheer and joy it's also a time
when people act like apples and so we'll
be going back to the uh am I the [ __ ]
Forum on Reddit for a little Christmas
themed Edition and we'll start here it
says my husband's family likes to drink
every holiday includes multiple bottles
of wines of wine slash cocktails I hate
drinking I have never drank my father
was an alcoholic I think it's childish
if you can't have fun without drinking
ironically it looks like she was drunk
while she wrote this because there's no
punctuation at all here this year I'm
hosting Christmas for a change I decided
since it's at my house no alcohol
allowed we are all getting older and
it's time to grow up how have you gotten
to the point of being an adult and you
you've never even heard of a combo this
is so common these days like people that
they don't even they have no idea
they've never heard of the concept so
they just they don't even bother there's
no comments here very few periods anyway
my husband's sister called to ask what
she could bring she saw a recipe for a
Christmas Martini that she wanted to
bring I told her about my no alcohol
rule she didn't say much but must have
told the rest of the family
some of them started texting me asking
me if I was serious and saying that it
is lame but I'm not budging now it turns
out my husband's sister is hosting an
all alternate Gathering that almost
everyone is choosing to go to instead
it's so disrespectful all because they
would have to spend one day sober my
husband told me he talked to his sister
and we are invited to her Gathering and
he said that we should just go and stop
causing issues but I won't it's so rude
now husband is mad because I'm making
him stay home and spend Christmas with
me but it was my turn to host and I
chose to have a no alcohol they could
have dealt with it for one year okay
you're the a-hole here without question
first of all how is drinking childish
you can't even legally drink until
you're three years into legal adulthood
so I'm not sure how it's childish
exactly second you intentionally made
your Christmas gathering Less Fun
and then got mad when people chose not
to come to it see you can't it's not the
way it works you can't do that you can
have your lame tea total or celebration
but you can't force people to attend
I'll have a bland and Bland with nothing
in it alcohol is not necessary to have a
good time something necessary
but it is a social lubricant and uh it's
not necessary but your prohibition on it
is not necessary this is just a it's
like a power trip and that's all this is
why would people want to go to your
event if you have unnecessarily made it
less fun that's what that's what you
have to ask yourself and also one other
point here because this is important I
think I think people this idea just like
commas this has fallen by the wayside
you know when you have guests over to
your house
your own Comfort is actually not
supposed to be the top priority like
yeah it's your house and you can do what
you want you can set whatever rules you
want but the comfort of your guests is
supposed to be the top priority and if
you're bringing them over for a holiday
celebration
the the most important thing to you in
the world should be that they have a
good time you should be more determined
to see them have a good time than for
you to have a good time there will be no
more partying
damn it and that's the way it's going to
work that's part of Hosting it's like
you're bringing on all of the
responsibility all the chores and
everything onto yourself
and you're doing all this so that your
family has a good time it's an act of
love
and if you're not if you're not ready to
take that on then it's probably better
for someone else to host the event
all right so you're the a-hole good that
was easy enough I am a happily Child
free adult well you're already the
a-hole I don't even need to read the
rest of this babies have always made me
super uncomfortable I don't like looking
at them
uh yeah I mean this is we've already
determined I don't think we need judge
jury and executioner we've already
decided we've already decided your
sentence I don't like looking at them
being in their presence or really
hearing about them I used to have panic
attacks if I had to be near a baby or
toddler even for a minute or two if a
baby or toddler touched me I'd freak out
and have to go wash off a few layers of
skin oh so you're mentally ill this is a
crazy person okay uh still the a-hole
but you know there's no Insanity plea to
get you out of the a-hole ruling
I don't know what caused such an intense
reaction but it's always been like this
I've been working on at least being more
cordial and tolerant with babies and
toddlers to the point that I no longer
have panic attacks so I'm glad you've
been working on that
however they still make me very
uncomfortable and I don't want anything
to do with them I have a friend we'll
call her Sally who knows that I do not
like babies and how uncomfortable they
make me Sally had a baby several months
back
could she do that how could she do that
to you have a baby when she knows how
you feel about them I was polite and
congratulated her ever since every so
often she'll randomly message me about
her baby she'll start with I know you
don't like babies but and then send
pictures of her baby tell me about toys
or clothes she bought for her baby Etc I
usually reply in brief messages like
nice or okay and leave it at that I
don't want to be mean so I just give the
minimal response I delete photos
immediately
because I'm not interested Sally and I
are not nor have we ever been close
friends recently sadly posted in a group
that uh chat that we're both in asking
for people's addresses if they want to
receive a Christmas card from her baby
that's how she awarded it I figured if I
didn't fill out the document that would
be an easy non-confrontational way to
ensure that I would not be receiving
baby pictures in the mail unfortunately
Sally message me privately today asking
for my address so that she could send a
Christmas card so my silent opt out is
no longer an option will I be the
[ __ ] if I tell her I don't want a
Christmas card from her baby
and to please stop sending me photos and
updates about said baby
I guarantee by the way that this that
this person has like you know of course
is a as a cat or a dog that she's
obsessed with
which by the way in both cases cat and
dog much dirtier than than babies are
babies aren't dirty at all in fact
actually if you if you like are
practicing basic hygiene with your
children and much more annoying too are
animals than babies so you're the a-hole
by a mile I mean you so you set like a
new a-hole standard here you win gold in
the a-hole Olympics I think just because
you naturally feel a certain way
or have always felt that way
that doesn't make it okay so we have
this idea these days that if you say
well you know I've always this is how I
feel about this I've always felt like
this that all all automatically all of a
sudden that makes okay it does it is not
okay to be repulsed by children it is
not okay to hate them okay it's like
actively not okay it's actually bigoted
that's how we need to start looking at
this people say I hate kids I don't like
kids that's that's a bigoted response
because think about it you this is a you
are confessing to
this Prejudice and it gets an entire
demographic of human beings and it
wouldn't be acceptable with any other
group you could think of unless you were
talking about white men then in our
culture that's okay so white men and
just all kids those are the two groups
you're allowed to despise except that
your your anti-child bigotry is the
least Justified bigotry on Earth because
you're hating the most innocent people
on the planet what is a baby ever done
to hurt you so this is not okay
um it's not okay to say to say no in
this case and I like to think that your
friend is fully aware of how this makes
you feel and it's just doing this to
torment you which I think makes me like
your friend even more my mom died when I
was seven my dad married a new woman
about a year later my stepmom who all
called Dory had a daughter much older
than me who I'll call Kylie my dad's
explanation for why things move so
quickly is because Dory and Kylie were
being evicted shortly after my dad
started seeing her and then he came to
say stay so I didn't know them very well
before they moved in oh my gosh this
thing is long we're going all the way
back to birth or to when she was seven I
were to get this entire story get all
the background details that we don't
need on Christmas when passing out gifts
I only received one from my parents this
was not something that was common in my
family as my dad makes a decent amount
of money and so Kylie and I would always
get at least a few gifts each Kylie and
her husband received multiple presents
and when I pointed out uh that out I was
told that it was because they needed
them for their new house and marriage my
present from my parents ended up being a
hairbrush Dory then made a big deal
about how she had forgotten the
stockings and would have to go get those
set up and handed out I assume this
meant that I was getting another gift in
the stocking when I was handed mine
there was a jewelry box in it I was very
excited when I opened it it was a golden
K necklace my name does not start with a
k when I pointed this out Dory said the
necklace was clearly meant for Kylie and
put it in the wrong stocking I agree
that made sense and then asked if Kylie
got the one meant for me and Dory said
that there was not one for me
tough brick I asked her if there was
anything else she had forgotten and Dory
said if there's nothing in your stocking
you clearly didn't get anything else at
this point I was frustrated and hurt
started to cry my dad ended up yelling
at me and saying that I was being
ungrateful and causing problems on
Christmas because some kids don't get
anything at all on Christmas he was mad
because he said that I caused a scene
instead of talking to him after the
holiday that I ruined Kylie and her
husband's first Christmas together ended
up leaving and going to stay with my
grandma for the rest of the break
however sometimes Dory will still
mention how spoiled I am for ruining the
holiday over not getting what I wanted
for Christmas and it really makes me
feel bad about myself so I have to ask
am I the a-hole for how I reacted okay
uh yes you are
and so is your your stepmom and your dad
and and Kylie is too we'll just throw
her in I assume she's probably at hell
this is a fan this seems to be a
family-wide phenomenon it sounds like a
miserable family my God uh what a
nightmare now it's clear that your evil
Cinderella stepmother was probably
trying to make a point here she was
using Christmas as a passive aggressive
way to make a point about how much she
hates you and prefers the other one so
that does seem pretty clear
but at the same time you're an adult
and it's just not under any circumstance
acceptable to complain about not getting
enough gifts or getting the wrong gifts
on Christmas
there's nothing that can make that okay
maybe if you open the box and there was
like Anthrax in it or a bomb then it
would be okay to complain but other than
that you take the gift
you give your phony thank you and and
that's it and then you leave and the
real response here is it's just you
don't go back to their house for
Christmas again because you see how they
treat you that's fine your dad said that
some kids don't get anything on
Christmas but you're not a kid right
you're at least in college you're an
adult
so this is just embarrassing for
everyone all around
everyone is an a-hole
all of you
you're disgusting
but Merry Christmas and uh Happy New
Year
[Music]